7.32 degrees so we want to take this
fraction of a degree the 0.32 and
convert it into minutes and seconds so
the first thing that you want to
understand is that there's 60 minutes in
one degree and there's 60 seconds in one
minute so if you think about you know a
circle a circle is like made up of 360
degrees say one degree is just like a
small you know fraction of the whole 360
degrees that make up a circle and then
that one degree you can subdivide that
into 60 minutes okay and then you could
take one of those minutes and then you
can subdivide that into 60 seconds so
there's actually 3600 seconds in one
degree okay because 60 times 60 you can
think of a degree as like an hour
there's 60 minutes in an hour there's 60
seconds in a minute
and there's 3600 seconds in one hour but
we're thinking of the hours okay those
are going to be degrees right so going
back to this problem if you take the
point three two degrees and you multiply
it by a conversion factor for every one
degree there are 60 minutes and so this
is the minute symbol it looks just like
the the feet symbol right that we often
see and so what we're doing is we're
just canceling the units we're
cancelling out the degree units okay
numerator and denominator we're ending
up with the minutes units so let's just
do this on our calculator 0.32 times 60
is how much it's nineteen point two so
that means we have nineteen point two
minutes okay so now you can see we've
got this fraction of a minute right here
there's 0.2 minutes let's go ahead and
take that fraction of a minute and let's
convert it into seconds so we've got 60
seconds okay there's two marks here for
seconds for every one minute these are
equal to one another
so we can use it as a unit conversion
factor and what we're gonna do now is
we're just going to cancel the numerator
and denominator the minutes that we're
left with seconds so 0.2 times 60 is 12
seconds so if we put it all back
together we've got seven degrees okay
that's this right here we've got let's
see 19 minutes that was from this one
here and we have 12 seconds so that's
how you convert from
degrees to degrees minutes and seconds
so I hope this video helped you
understand how to work with us a little
bit better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon